皆さんこんにちは私は春と申します
早速ですがいきなり詰問したいと思います
私の性別なんだと思いますか
分かる方はどれだけいることでしょうか
この状況の中で皆さんは何を基準に私の性別を考えましたでしょうか
おそらく今のこの状況で判断できるも残せはまずは私の体格
着ている服などの外見次に話し方であったり
ての振る舞い方などを見て判断されていると思います
また春という名前からも考えられることだとは思います
普段の生活私の普段の生活の中では基本的には男性として扱われています
という方をするとあれ外見と違って実は男性じゃないのっていうふうに思う方も
いらっしゃると思います
とその他にですね男女のほかに多様な性ということで最近は lgbt
などレディアで見ることもあると思います
このような多様な性を考えた方もいると思います
lgbt 匹ならない方もいると思いますので簡単に説明をすると
リガーレズビア
恋愛対象として女性を好きになる女性 g が上げ
恋愛対象として男性を好きになる男性 b がバイセクシャル
両性愛男性も女性も好きになる方ですね
でトランスジェンダー戸籍上の生物に対して違和感を持っている方を指します
こういうふうに言うとさらにさっきまでの男女という二択ではなくて
さんに lgbt ということも追加されジャガー lgbt のどれかというふうに
お考えの方もいると思います
でも実際のところは私が本当のことを言わなければ
lgbt なのか男女なのかという事もわからないですよね
おそらくなりないだろうということは分かるとは思います
こういった質問されてなんという質問なんだというふうに驚いた方もいるかと思います
が少し混乱されている方もいると思いますので
性別について4つの視点から整理しながらお話ししたいと思います
その後に私の性別を伝えしたいと思います
はいまずは心の性別ですね
自分のことを男性と農家女性と思うか自分の感覚ですね
次に体の性生殖器がどうなっているか
染色体がどのようになっているかという生物学的な青ですです気のせい
恋愛対象が男性なのか女性なのか
らしさのせ世の中には男らしい仕草
女らしい仕草や服装天皇があると思いますが自分はどんな性別としているマイたいかと
いう聖ですね
では
ここまでをお伝えしとなく上で私の性別
これにあてはめてお話ししたいと思います
心の性別自分のことは男性だと思っていますので男性です
体の性も生まれた時から男性です
で好きの恋愛対処は自分の場合は男性というふうになります
で出したの性は男性ですので
lg 生きていうなればジャン正当性愛者ということになります
同性愛者の方を見るというのは初めてという方もいらっしゃるかもしれませんですね
自分の場合は恋愛対象は男性かもしれないと思ったのは中学2年生の頃でした
で8 lgb 家のことや多様な性のことについて話すようになったのは23年前です
23年前は私は同性愛者ですとその一言を言うだけにも涙が流れてしまう
そんな状況でした
小さい頃からテレビの中では女性愛車は笑われるものから変われるもの
そして学校の中ではいじめられるもの
そんなイメージがありました
10代の頃は自分はいつかは10代の頃はどうせありは
いつか治るという言葉を信じていました
高校に入っても大学に入ってもハタチになってもその言葉を信じています
しかし形になっても
なっても女性を好きになることはできたん
そんな自分が何者かというふうに襲われます
自分は何者なのかそれを確かめたい
そこで私は取った手段としてはネットを通じて同じような人と出会うということでした
世の中としてはネットを通じて出会うそれはいわゆる出会い系だとか
危険だという行為です
しかしそれ以外に私には方法が思いつきませんでした
親にも言えない友達にも言えない
自分の気持ちを素直に言えないことはても寂しく孤独です
そしてもにもなのかわからないその状態がいつわかるのか
ただただ自分が何者なんか怖かっ
同じような同性愛沙
両性愛者の方とあの中で
僕たちは同じ種だから君は変じゃないよという思いはできます
だけど
僕たちは違う目
もちろん君はじゃないよという思いは
なかなかせ人にいましたん
僕たちは家亀だけど変じゃない
君は素敵だよそんな一言がいい
聞きたくて渋滞を過ごしています
僕たちは違うね
だけど編著ないよという至るまでにはまずは自分が違うということ
あなたが思っている自分と実際の自分は違うということを伝えなければいけません
それを lgbt であることセクシャルマイノリティであることを伝えることを
カミングアウトと言います
が明があったという言葉は日常生活でもテレビでも見かけることがあると思いますが
自分のですね l カミングアウトするときの感覚をお伝えしたいと思います
底の見えない暗闇の中で植え方が皿垂れ下がってユーロップに
千頭ついている状態
これがカミングアウトできていない状態です
とりあえずここのロップ歳しがみついていればを知ることもね
聞かをすることもないん
とりあえず安全
しかしこの手を離さずということはどうなのか
力を抜くこともできない
だけど自由に自分の人生を歩きたいそう思ったときにはそのでそのロックから手を離し
飛び降りなければいけないそう思いました
ポリった先がどんな風になったら彼は見えません
コツコツしたよ肌で落ちてしまえば怪我をするかもしれない
死んでしまうかもしれない
をれなければよかったと後悔するかもしれない
もしかしたらネットのようにふわふわで暖かく包み込んでくれる場所かもしれない
かもしれないということだけ確信を持つことはできません
なぜならクラ8名で何も見えないからです
その中から
大丈夫だよ
俺ちゃおいてといっ
声が聞こえたら
どんな抱くでしょうか
ひとによってカミングアウトしやすい相手というのはそれぞれだと思います
自分の場合は長い付き合いにある人ほど伝えることができませんです
仙台の大学を休学し東京に出てそこで出会った人には
いうことができました
しかし取れまちゃんとまた父はいうことができませんでした
失ってしまうのではないか
それを考えると細くてえませんでした
それならバック履かしていくよ
と思っていました
ただ両親には支えろそう考えています
言えなかったからあの時辛かったんだ
と後から言いたくないそう思いました
同性愛者になるのは育て方が悪いという人や
カミングアウトされたをやがっ
自分の育て方が悪かったのではないかとねハムという話も聞きます
おとうさんもおかあさん何も悪くはない
ありがとう育ててくれてありがとうその気持ちは変わりはない
他の兄弟と同じ家に同じように暮らして出すなのになんでだろう
結婚もできないし mabo 3時られない
ごめんねとっ
カミングアウトした後のことされた親のことも考えなければいけないと思っ
受け止められるだろうか納谷気がしないだろうか
それもとても不安だったヘ gpt のこと自分のこと
このように人前で話すことはそれまでにもあります
だから大丈夫だろうそう思って臨みました
ん
だけど大勢の中の誰か心に響いてくれば
くれればというのではなく
このように他にない両親には理解されたいそんな想いだとてもありました
たみんあとは私の夏
カミングアウトするただそれだけのために実家へ帰ります
帰ったその日の夜に伝えました
その日のうちには8ックリ話ができずモヤモヤした気持ちのまま
目ぶりにつきました
席の位置に海に入ってて彼砂浜で2時間話をしました
海から家への帰り道
ち違うん提訴で車ふと前を見ると必要にがこんなしぐさをしていました
自分は
何も声をかけることができませんです
泣いているのかもしれないそう思ったけどダサ眺めてるだけでした
やはり悩ませてしまったのかもしれないただそう思っていました
家に帰るといつもと変わらない夕食がありました
混ぜて昨日ぬカミングアウトなんて無かったことのようで
たまらず自分が聞いてしまいました
もし自分に恋人が出来て
ただ紹介してもいいの
紹介していいに決まってるじゃん
とその返事にうまく答えられずわかったそうするとしか言えませんでした
見送りの最後
2人の子どもでよかったよありがとうということが消えました
当事者と非同時車
お互いに分かり合えないこともあります
それまでの人生考え方聞いてきたもの
同じ気持ちになるといってもそれは簡単なことではありません
だけどヒートを自社と自社という言葉ではなくてお互いにこうやって顔の見える関係と
して感情のある人間だということを認識した上で
一緒にこれからを生きていこうその気持ちにはなれるのではないでしょうか
いろんな人がいてもいいという言葉は聞きますが
それは他の人が生き安来という社会ではなくここにいる皆さん
あなたもより
いろんな生き方をしてもいいいろんなあり方があってもいいということです
普段の生活の中でしゅっ職業や年齢出身
いろんな属性があると思います
そしてその中で自分の役割であったり責任であったり
抱えていることもあるでしょう
そしてこのことは誰にも言えないと思っている人もいるでしょう
こんな自分がこんなことをしてはいけない
他の人もそうしているし
わがままだと思われるかもしれないそうやって我慢してやりたいことをやらなかったり
していませんか
楽しく生きたい笑っていきたい好きに愛さと一緒に暮らしてい
わくわく歳
思いっきり抱きたいいろんな思いがあると思います
そんないろんな想いに
一人一人の思いに耳を傾けた社会
同じ価値観やち合わせではなく
一人ひとりがそれぞれ違って価値観や幸せがあると思います
そんな時に一人一人に合わせるということは手間のかかることかもしれません
一人一人の思うこともやって伝えることも
司令の形ではなく
こんな風に侮辱罪になってしまうこともあると思います
だけどそれを聞いてくれる人を伝えてもいいんだと思えるこの環境
そんな風な社会こそ多様線や触れ
豊かな社会だと私は思います
例えば
わがままかもしれないこんなことをしてはいけないと思った時にこう言ってもらえる
ような
気にしなくていいんだよ
みんなそうやって生きているから
ありがとうございます